TURN.
NIC ROBERTSON HAS OUR STORY.
>> FOR MORE THAN 150 YEARS,
ALMOST UNINTERRUPTED, BIG BEN
ICONIC BIG BONGS, THE HOURLY
CHIMES HAVE RUN OUT ACROSS
LONDON.
BUT NOW THE FAMOUS CLOCK BELT
FROM WHERE BIG BEN GETS ITS NAME
WILL FALL QUIET FOR URGENT
REFURBISHMENT WORK, STARTING
NEXT YEAR.
THE BRITISH PARLIAMENT HAS
ANNOUNCED THE ELIZABETH TOWER,
WHICH HOUSES THE CLOCK, WILL
UNDERGO THREE YEARS OF REPAIRS.
>> THERE ARE A COUPLE OF AREAS
THAT WE DO DESPERATELY WANT TO
LOOK AT.
THE SUSPENSION SPRING, THE
PENDULUM, WE'RE HOPING TO TAKE
THE HANDS OFF THE CLOCK.
>> DECADES OF WEATHER AND WATER
DAMAGE HAVE CAUSED PARTS OF THE
METAL AND STONEWORK IN THE TOWER
TO CRUMBLE.
THERE HAS BEEN NO MAJOR
REPAIRWORK SINCE THE 1980s.
EVEN THE BELLS THEMSELVES ARE
RUSTING.
THE IRON ROOF WILL BE REMOVED
COMPLETELY DURING THE WORKS,
MEANING THERE WILL BE SEVERAL
MONTHS OF SILENCE, WHEN THE
BELLS WON'T CHIME.
>> ON MY LEFT HERE IS THE
SOUTH-FACING CLOCK FACE.
>> EVEN THE CLOCK FACE IS BEING
ERODED.
>> YOU CAN SEE, THERE'S A
CONSIDERABLE PROBLEM WITH WATER
INGRESS HERE.
THERE'S RUST IN THE FRAMES.
THE MASTIC IS COMING AWAY HERE.
THE WATER COMES DOWN THE GLASS
AND GETS BEHIND THAT AND CAUSES
THIS TO RUST.
>> Reporter: THE TEAM IS
EXAMINING WHETHER TO RETURN THE
CLOCK FACE TO ITS ORIGINAL
VICTORIAN COLORS OF GREEN AND
GOLD.
BUT THEY PROMISE, AT LEAST ONE
OF THE FOUR FACES WILL ALWAYS BE
KEPT VISIBLE AND ON TIME AND
THAT THE BELLS WILL BE RUNG, AS
USUAL, ON MAJOR